PC Harper's Widow Lisi spent a day in
court she listened to the grim details
of her husband's last minutes alive the
couple had been married a month when he
was called to a burglary and was dragged
to his death behind a fleeing car
it happened in rural Berkshire last
summer the two officers had finished
their shift but worked close by and went
to help the suspects were towing a
stolen quad bike jurors were told it was
in a dark country lane that PC Harper
and his colleague confronted the
suspects car as the car sped off PC
Harper's feet got tangled up in the tow
rope he was dragged along for more than
a mile at speeds averaging 42 miles per
hour swung said the prosecutor like a
pendulum as the driver tried to dislodge
him the prosecutor said when at last he
became disentangled he was left with the
most awful injuries from which he died
there on the road surrounded by
colleagues who tried in vain to save him
his injuries were simply not survivable
and he could not be saved
he died totally naked apart from his
socks and boots and some shredded
remnants of the trousers he was wearing
this was a completely senseless killing
of a young police officer in the line of
duty
the officers Widow left Court as jurors
were shown police dashcam footage of the
bloody trail left by the escaping car in
the dark are Henry long 18 and 2 17-year
old boys who can't be named because of
their age they all deny murder but they
admit a plot to steal the quad bike
Henry long admits being the car driver
and has pleaded guilty to manslaughter
the prosecutor said it was a ludicrous
idea that he didn't know PC Harper was
tied to his car the three defendants
were arrested at a traveler's caravan
site later the same night the prosecutor
said long tolled brazen lies in police
interviews the others said nothing
jurors were shown police dashcam footage
of the moment the defendants car raced
off they heard PC
as fellow officer swear and radio in
I've lost my colleague Martin brunt Sky
News at the Old Bailey